oh god
okay
hi
this is perfectly normal it's perfectly
normal to join me here
in the dark but i'm here to test out a
theory and that theory is
what's the brightest flashlight on
amazon i bought several flashlights i
don't know how because i can't exactly
count how many are there because i can't
see them but there are several
flashlights here that claim to be the
world's most powerful flashlight now
obviously there's a problem with that
right off the bat because how can you
have the world's most powerful
flashlight multiple times now the
world's most powerful light probably
definitely not even in a handheld
capability it's probably like a star or
something or like a quasar or like
lighthouse or something like the
lighthouse lamp from lighthouse the
movie either way
i'm here to test out this capability
because i dropped a lot of money on this
stuff and if i'm gonna drop a lot of
money on this stuff i'm going to make a
video about it as you're going to see in
the future about another video that went
awry even before it started we'll get to
that later don't worry about it now you
don't need to worry about it now don't
even ask about it now because you're
going to find out about it later it's
not even like a like this video kind of
thing and then you'll find out about it
you will find out about it later just
don't ask questions
i am very responsible with my money okay
so uh how dark is it you might be asking
uh well it's a dork i've got another
camera angle here that shows how dark it
is it's dark and as a baseline i'm going
to turn on my phone's flashlight now
this is a flashlight everyone's like
look this is wrong way yes it was wrong
way uh everyone's looking at their
flashlight and they're like okay the
phone's flashlight is pretty good it'll
get you through the dark and at the end
of the day that's what a flashlight is
supposed to do when you've been
kidnapped by the vich in the woods and
you're in a basement somewhere and you
don't know where you are
you want one of these
okay
pretty good
you can see in the other camera it's not
bad it's got a good throw i think that's
as bright as it gets
oh my god please don't leave me alone
it's kind of adjustable you can make it
lighter or lower if you really want to
but you don't have to but that's as
bright as it gets and that's pretty
bright see not bad
not bad at all you can actually see me a
little bit so this is a baseline
flashlight and i wanted to show you this
because now it's time to get into the
good stuff these are what claim to be
the world's most powerful flashlights
the world's most powerful flashlight as
if ow
i don't know why i have this here so the
first one that we have here
is
so this is
a 50 light that's a good chunk of change
you can buy like 10 boxes of cereal well
you can't buy as much cereal as you used
to because of shrink flation if you
didn't know about shrink-flation it's
the practice by which companies make
their products smaller without you
knowing about it so that they can keep
the price the same to match with
inflation but it's trixie okay because
eventually everything's going to be so
small and small and small and then
suddenly the king size is what the
normal size was a few years ago and then
everything is smaller so that they can
make more profits originally it was just
a match with inflation so the consumers
wouldn't be too upset by increased
prices but now it's just a profit-making
scheme and all the companies are doing
it and i would not be surprised if this
was shrink-flated that's a topic for
another day and i'm not going to get
into that right now because i don't have
time actually i've got all the time in
the world but i don't have the sanity
for it and i do not have a lot of that
to spare i'm going to call this umar i
feel like an ungar is coming out of this
name
oh my god my eyes okay now that i've
adjusted to that that's pretty bright
bam that's really bright as you can see
on the other cam it's almost as if i
turned the light on in here that is i'm
not gonna look in it
okay all right this is why i brought
these
i've got multiple sunglasses and at the
end of the day a flashlight is just a
sun in the palm of your hand
oh no
all right we're layered up
oh god jesus christ this is not a good
idea
here i go
okay so three layers it took three
layers of sunglasses to beat this
flashlight i guess that's the metric
that i'm gonna go with and i'm gonna
remember what order that i put this in
or i'm going to forget because i'm an
idiot but i'm going to remember that
this was the order that this came in
this is a pretty good start ungar has
done pretty good here and it's still
pretty bright i can't look at it
directly or else it gets holes in my
retina but this is definitely extremely
bright don't try this at home by the way
this is a bad idea so that's pretty good
not bad 50 bucks i think it was i'll
probably look it up on amazon later so i
can actually remember which one of these
was it was i pulled them out because i
was
curious and bored so i
kind of busted them open so i could see
him before i actually got
why would it ever need a strobe function
i can't see i got sunglasses on how am i
going to remember what i had
if i didn't have sunglasses on
this that
that sure yeah okay and i've got these
i tried to get increasingly bigger so i
could fit them over each other so this
went to three so that's a three out of
five sunglasses that's pretty good but
not that good back to the normal
flashlight alright so next up is another
nameless box that i have no idea what it
is this is the things not going as
expected some of these immilant there it
is they have their names this is
[Music]
the imminent one okay so this one's
chode like whereas this one's like got
length but no girth while this one is
all girth all day which is a different
approach like both are good in their own
way ideally you want length and girth
but
you know gotta make sacrifice so i'm not
gonna point that on my eyes because that
would be a bad idea i'm gonna finger it
until i find the power button
oh ooh chanco
okay chancobonko that is
is that brighter it seems like it's
brighter because it seems like it's got
a bit more spread i'll know more when i
get to the sunglasses test but my
goodness that's nice it's got a nice
tight focused beam yeah
and it's got some splash damage on there
so sunglasses test i'm just gonna go
straight to three i'm not even gonna
risk burning my retinas i think this is
just as bright or brighter so i'm gonna
go three right away
oh that is difficult at three and it's a
lot more you can't see this at all
there's no there's no way you'd be able
to see this but there's an array of
jesus christ i gotta go for four okay
four
that's manageable jesus okay so it's got
an array of uh
led diodes or whatever they're called i
don't even know if that's a direct name
for them i'm not a flashlight expert but
as i'm counting this it's got 18
different diodes where i think this one
only has four in a tight grid so the
beam is tighter as you can see it's like
a
a pretty good circle while this one's
spread around because of the number of
them but it's packed in the center with
four and then it's a ring around them so
this one's got more spread but if you
want a focused like interrogation beam
this one's going to do it but this one
with the more lights is just brighter
and i can actually feel the heat i
wonder if any of these could light a
fire
as you can see with both of them
together it's
it's bright it's wide i am going to ruin
my eyes so that's a four out of five
sunglasses which is not bad i don't know
what the battery life is on all these
this was about the same price i think
this was 60 bucks actually so
comparatively they're pretty good but
one thing you've got to consider is that
when you're facing down to the vic and
you've only got your flashlight this
one's got some weapon power you know you
can really get some good like momentum
going on this this one's just chungo
so like you can't really get a lot of
like power going into it you just hit
with a little tip here you might bang
your knuckles against her like jagged
teeth and you know when you're trying to
like get away from her long claws are
gonna like rip this right out of your
hands i and you can't even get a full
grip around it like it's just that
girthy and like when you're when you're
thinking of something that you can
really squeeze like that you want a full
wrap around grip so that you've got that
locked in your hand and when her claws
and her spells are making your muscles
just fight against you and you're trying
to relax your grip and you're like no i
don't want to go into the cauldron this
ain't coming loose but this you're just
like i guess i'm soup tonight and then
you're dead so glad we cleared that up
uh okay [ __ ] gear light okay this
one's [ __ ] i didn't even bother
unboxing this actually all of them from
now on have been not unboxed
this was the cheapest one we're going
cheapsies not that i always go cheapsies
but we're going cheapsies and the reason
we're going cheapsies is because these
other ones these are rechargeable which
is great they've got lithium batteries
lithium batteries as far as i know are
pretty damn good they're rechargeable
they can run through multiple cycles at
least a few hundred and i don't know how
many times you're charging up a
flashlight but honestly how many do you
need this is getting annoying i prefer
the darkness
so now i can't see anything ah there it
is okay so it's kind of [ __ ] more
like gear [ __ ] get out of gear
you're stuck grinding in between the
gears it really grinds my gears because
it does not include batteries it says it
takes four aaa batteries and those are
not included okay well i guess it's
cheap so maybe that's the point i don't
even know if it's as bright maybe all
the price really is in the batteries
okay so we got a little bit of a mixture
here kind of like got half chungo
and it's not even that chungo it's only
moderately thicker than this one shorter
two kind of a stubby little one not as
stubby as this obviously but this made
it up with girth oh it's only got one
diode i don't even know if that's the
right terminology but i think it is it
requires four triple a oh it's got oh
it's adjustable
it can get longer it can grow erect all
right well still not as much but you
know it was a bit of a grower not so
much a shower either way i'm still mad
but if this pumps out like a lot of
light
for four triple a's
i won't be too upset about it
the resealable batteries what a concept
they stole technology from oreo packages
to make battery holders how many times
have you i've bought the like big sams
club battery packs and every time as
soon as i get halfway down they jostle
together they start touching they
corrode and then all the batteries are
gone so that's nice
duracell
brand deal me i will say terrible things
about you if you don't get a brand
i just like to extort brand deals out of
companies it works every time let me
tell you every time i feel like i'm
loading up a
gun magazine reloading
that's what you'll have to do when
you're facing off of the vic that's
afraid of that light but you got an
unlimited source of aaa batteries or
double a batteries and really reloading
you get this done in like 2.5 seconds
reloading getting the gear
getting the gear
don't worry about it
okay safety was off on that what the
hell see that's scary that's scary
this is
this is terrible oh my god oh my god
stop oh my god i want to die i wanna die
okay what does the extendo do erect
okay all right you know i was
hesitant at first but
i
actually very much enjoy that and it's
great because this finally replicates
that video game effect where you can
like zoom your flashlight i always
thought that was [ __ ] but i didn't
know that you could just
[Music]
burn it away
like that's actually a thing you can do
holy crap it's not like the most like
this is like maybe a one or two
sunglasser yeah this is like a two
sunglasser but even so i bet if i focus
this it would turn into a three or a
four you know it's really like honing in
the light
oh yeah that's oh my god yeah that's a
four that's a four baby that's a four
yeah that's i shouldn't look at that
yeah that's that's bad i'm doing
horrible damage to my eyes do not do
this actually i'm not because i'm being
safe but don't try this i'm a
professional
boom so honestly what's happening
oh it flickers oh interesting it's a
flickering light okay this light is
haunted
that's the bottom line of this this
light is actually haunted but what do
you want when you're facing off the
ethereal demons that got you like
trapped in the woods
you want a haunting of your own not bad
okay as far as like favorites go this is
definitely tops this was second honestly
for a 15 flashlight it does run on
regular alkaline it's not rechargeable
but you could find rechargeable
batteries probably and put them in here
that are the same size as double a's and
i bet you would just have to pop them
out to reload you wouldn't just be able
to plug in a flashlight like these are
but hey
that's cool you can really hurt someone
with this
you are having a bad day which it's a
little finicky on the power
is this like flashing out sos or
something
it is
that's an automated sos
oh like long long long
o s s that's sos
i don't know how i did that but i did it
that puts this up there's a second place
for me i still like the weight and heft
and rechargeability of this and the
power that you get baseline but the
flexibility of this one if this had
rechargeable batteries it would be my
top
and if it was a little longer and
slightly girthier all right you know
what actually gear light you know i i
will let you get in my gears you're like
you you are you're a gear good get ready
for power style i think it's like
probably the same as doggy style or
missionary style you're gonna get
loud with power power light energy
saving waterproof explosion proof why
does it need to be it literally says
explosion proof okay so we got another
chungo ooh but this time we got a chungo
with finger holes okay so you got a
tight grip it's a little bit on the low
end of the grip like i don't know who's
choking up on the grip on their
flashlight like
i don't know who's
you hear that it's like a pneumatic
little hiss
power style baby
hello windows okay i don't know if you
can really see does that design really
come across it might just be a blotted
out but to me that is straight up the
windows logo but what if i do this
it's the big boy version of that one
there look at this uh
circle that's really cool it's really
making these flicker it's really really
not the right frame rate for these
lights here but you know that's pretty
bright but we're still not like in the
super bright range i bet this is this
seems like about the same as this one or
probably this i think this might be
identical to this one because this one
was also a four grid this is probably
the same led like fixture but to be
honest like just the flexibility is
pretty cool the only thing i hate about
it is just the handling like i don't
want to grab onto this i don't want to
grab onto that that doesn't make sense
but i do love
the hiss the feel it's got great build
quality this was another like 50 or 60
dollar one like most of the ones here
are around the 50 to 60 range this was
actually the only cheapo and frankly
this one surprised me let's do a little
test i'm gonna turn all the lights on at
once
oh
hey that's pretty good it's like a
bright sunshiny day okay you know what
until something like surprises me i
think this is all going to be about the
same i know this is the same power as
this so i'm not even going to bother
checking it it's a three it's a three
out of five sunglasses but really like
this isn't a metric of quality this is
just a metric of brightness get all
these off get it back into sweet blessed
darkness so the vic doesn't find me
actually in the darkness is definitely
when it can find you in fact it's
looking at me right now
guys please
like the video to protect me from the
vivid it's the only ritual that'll save
me subscribe ring that bell if you don't
subscribe ring that bell if the [ __ ] is
going to kill me please i'm begging you
please now now would be the time now
it'll be that time
thank you for that by the way you saved
my life you really did if you didn't
know from now on you have to like
subscribe and ring the bell or else
i'm gone is that manipulative probably
not okay this one is made in china i
didn't open this one
if it wasn't clear by the plastic
oh ooh
what is this oh it's got a power oh it's
own power plug
neat whoa this is a chongus look at the
chongus it's roughly the same design but
this one is just slightly chongaser
damn it's a lightsaber
hello ah there's insulating plastic
inside sometimes they do that for the
leds just so they don't discharge on the
way out or i'm going to blow up or
something again in the 50 to 60 dollar
range guys please like like the video
now if it's just coming i gotta get the
screwed in
okay well
that's
underwhelming is there any power
adjustment is that
is this really it
it's a it's a flashlight right my
problem is all of these said
the world's most powerful flashlight
every one of these said that and this
isn't even as powerful as this one what
is this is pathetic it's not even
adjustable i mean this one wasn't
adjustable either but at least this one
like impressed me at first this one's
better to hold than this one too it's
got a weird grip god shut up go away
i'm gonna be disappointed from now on
right this one is the xo02lnsjmbxhp
xhp70.2 flashlight that's i'm not just
making that up that is the name of this
that's the least inspired name i've ever
heard in my life that is the most
pathetic naming scheme
of anything that i've i'm just my
disappointment is immeasurable this
looks
this is the exact same i'll turn it on
[Music]
this is disappointing i'm gonna remember
this is the one and this is the new one
get out of here what is that all about
what a waste of my money all of this was
just a big waste i spent
50 100 120 170 100 and 220 270
270 i spent on those and two of them i
hate one of them i don't like one of
them is okay this one surprised me and
this one was good reliable this is the
one i would go with because that one's
the identical design is this you know i
did like this one very versatile but
honestly none of these amaze me
none of these have amazed me which is
why i have one more
i knew that all these would not be
qualifying as the world's most powerful
flashlight i knew this i knew this for a
fact please like the video or else i am
going to be good
i need more subscribers right now please
oh my god if you're watching this you
haven't subscribed i make really cool
videos and if you want me to be able to
spend more money on more crap on amazon
please get it now okay thank you that
was close now yes
yeah
i have here something more substantial
than the other ones i don't even know
where everything is
this
is what is this called the immolent
which is the same as that other one
isn't that the same as the chongo in
mayland yeah same same okay so
little chungus here
same company that made this one
this is the
ms 18 imalent
tame
the sun
100 000 lumens
okay
now
this
this uh
don't judge me this
cost
hundred
dollars
10 times
10 10
times
more expensive than any of these other
flashlights it was actually over 500 i
don't remember the specifics but it
might have been close to 600
let's round up and say 600. and let me
tell you
jesus christ
let me tell you
when i say
[Music]
it's worth every penny i had to test
this out to make sure that i wouldn't
blow up before i was able to film
this video and honestly
i'm still
not 100 sure if i won't blow up when i
turn this thing on this thing has a
warning a warning you cannot shine this
at any human
ever this is meant to throw a light up
to a mile away this can illuminate the
grand canyon so when i turn this on i'm
warning you
avert
your eyes because the sun
[Music]
you with that that's the lowest setting
it goes up from here it's a safety
feature okay next level
brighter next level
brighter we're at 5 000 lumens i'm gonna
start putting on sunglasses just because
i know for a fact this [ __ ] goes next
level
that's 10 000 lumens
okay
twenty thousand lumens is this twenty
thousand this might be twenty thousand
okay all right
okay that's
thirty i think this might be thirty okay
we're going up to sixty i think next
oh
oh and then the fan kicks on
okay we've whited out the entire screen
up there it's really bright it is lit up
this entire room as if it's day that's
the power and it has to kick a fan i'm
actually gonna turn it off
i didn't even make it to a hundred
thousand lumens there is something
special you have to do to get to a
hundred thousand lumens and you this is
probably hot that's why the fan kicks on
because it gets so hot that it can i'm
curious if it can burn through paper i
can't see a thing let me turn on my
light
yeah i got to find my phone here oh it's
somewhere in here it's somewhere
oh jesus christ oh my god okay thank you
oh wow a reasonable amount of light okay
so somewhere in here there's a user
guide here we go that's gonna tell me
how to activate 100k mode and 100k mode
cannot go
for very long because otherwise it'll
burn the flashlight out and then i'll
burn my house down okay turbo double
press the power switch button at any
mode it will activate turbo double press
the power switch again we'll activate
strobe slightly press the power switch
button to exit so what i don't want to
do is turn on strobe 100 lumen mode that
sounds terrifying i'm putting on
multiple sunglasses for this one uh we
were just at 60 000 lumens okay we're
about to go to 100 000. 60 000
double press
i'm not gonna shine this in my eyes i'm
gonna assume that's a six out of five
sunglasses the only thing that i'm gonna
try is to see if that if it will light
this paper on fire and if it does this
will not be in the video because for
god's sake i don't want anyone to try
this
that's hot
didn't even make it warm okay that's
fine then all right cool maybe all that
was overblown but this is unequivocally
unequivocably
the world's most powerful flashlight
maybe i bet they make more powerful than
this and i'm closing my eyes i want to
see if i can see my see it through my
eye oh it's very hot up here actually
it's quite warm
ah
oh my god it's daylight
the sun got in here jesus christ
it smells like something burning i think
the vich has lit her cauldron i need to
run as fast as i can but with this
she won't stand a chance so thank you so
much for watching remember to like and
uh subscribe
to prevent me from being captured by the
witch and hopefully i will survive the
night but i know that with this oh you
hit the button with this by my side
nothing will stand in my way and then as
a backup i can have one of these other
ones like little jungle here you know
just like it's a sidearm and then my
main flashlight nothing's gonna get in
my way this is probably illegal
to take anywhere in public thank you so
much for watching hope you enjoyed it i
know i did
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye